it almost seems kind of
counter-intuitive for them to kill pablo
though right because
cause pablo was was fueling this whole
thing
why would they kill him well they didn't
kill him he killed himself
but they set things in motion that
killed him with his with his enemies
it was his own men that hunted him down
in the end the castano brothers were in
charge of the operation
they were head of the death squad last
pepes and don
burner was their lieutenant who was on
the ground who went into the house with
his brother seed
there was some cops there but they
always sent los pepes in the death squad
first
and then they would have to disappear
because they were in a legal death squad
and the police would take the credit
police was [ __ ] themselves about
pablo but they were using technology
with
you know to track him down with the
authorities and working with the
authorities
right right so they go in the castano
brothers have announced
that they're going to capture pablo
alive
they're going to have his arms and legs
surgically removed
and they're gonna keep him alive and
they're gonna throw the stumps on medium
the king of medellin is now you know
this the stump
and that would guarantee their legend
they were gonna chop his kids up and
send them to him in a sack
now pablo died because of the love of
his family he stayed on the phone for
too long
he caused the end to happen and he
always said to his men
he's got his famous six-hour pistol he's
going to shoot off so many bullets and
then he's going to put one in his head
look at how you know the line that
bullet went through almost one
almost perfect line through one ear and
to the other ear slightly out of place
but
he'd been shot three times i think it
was three times
he'd been shot in the knee um he'd been
shot in the shoulder
and one of the bullets would end up
lodged between his his teeth
it was over for him and he knew that he
had to
he had to go get out the way to save his
family he sacrificed himself for the
love of his family and that's what's
interesting about him is these
contradictions
this guy who authorized genital
electrocution and torture
one of the torches they had was they
would put rags with petrol into your
mouth
with you know gas that runs cars into
your mouth until your eyeballs pop down
they would they wouldn't just kill you
they would kill whole generations of
your family
yeah his love for his family was so
strong you know he died for his family
now he was made the boogeyman because he
went to war with the government instead
of just kicking back
it was people according to jorge val
george valdez
there was people bigger than him who
kicked back and stayed out the headlines
and in the night in the 1980s when pablo
was making all this news war with the
government
you know felix gallardo was rising up as
the mexican cartel boss without making
any news headlines whatsoever
that was a far shredder strategy yeah
when they took the colombians down that
you know the mexicans took over because
it doesn't matter which country you take
down another country's going to pick you
up because the profit margin is so high
because of drug laws
but the feds need a boogie man so you
know el
was just at el chapo yeah who's it going
to be next
have you read have you read the book of
pablo's brother
i've read all the books on pablo plus
i've got all of the books that have been
written about pablo in spanish
translated into english
because i've just written the longest
book ever about pablo four book series
over a thousand pages called pablo
escobar's story
which completely transformed getting all
these translations completely
transformed my understanding
of what happened and you're releasing
this when
it's already released i just released
part three this week this week
yeah oh it's a it's a series okay so you
just released part three
yeah just released part three so part
four is the only one remaining now
wow yeah yeah the the first my first
introduction to that whole
world was when i read the accountant
story uh
from his brother what did you see did
you
when you read that i mean i felt like
the perspective of that book was kind of
unique to everything else because he was
the only one living right that was that
close to him
yeah and that's what took me on the
scent to get closer to the truth because
all the people living close to him or
working for him
his wife his mistress virginia vallejo
his main hitman popeye all those people
had written books that were only in
spanish back then
and the guys that were there when he
died
in charge of the operation carlos
castano wrote my confession
don burner wrote killing the boss all in
spanish still not in english
all the truth is in the spanish-speaking
world now i learned this because i wrote
a book called pablo escobar beyond
narcos
i did a talk in london and the colombian
woman came up to at the end and said
there's far more that you don't know in
the spanish-speaking world
everything written in the
english-speaking world was incentivized
and through the lens of certain agendas
such as the dea
you know the american heroes go in and
kick the bad guys's ass
that's what narcos has portrayed it's a
dea perspective
right there was an opportunity for juan
pablo to give his input
to narcos and the dea threatened to pull
out
so there's an agenda here it's the war
on drugs
the dea are the good guys the us federal
government is
you know holier than thou protecting
kids from evil drug dealers
while the cia is bringing the drugs in
wow man
jesus that agenda must be protected at
all costs to keep the war on drugs
go in but it's falling down
all this violence we're seeing now the
social under arrest
i think the war on drugs is tearing the
fabric of society apart because
the profit margin the the amount of
drugs sold every year illegally gets
bigger they estimate half a trillion to
a trillion dollars
and it's the biggest opportunity in the
history of the world for criminal
organizations
including intelligence agencies to make
the most profits ever out of anything
so they're all competing and that's
what's causing all this violence in
mexico and all the knife crime in london
what the media isn't telling you the
majority of it is is
drug gangs competing and criminals
competing for the black market profits
created by drug laws
you